[Musique]
je vous ai connu des enfants c'est toute
ta vie ma femme maya et architectes on a
décidé que ce serait mieux que je
m'occupe des enfants peut dire que c'est
un système qui fonctionne bien l'énergie
que ça ressemble un système carcéral
la pêche
c'est bientôt mon anniv il ya longtemps
a profité à tous les deux vous étiez
tellement trajet grandi depuis j'ai pas
envie de passer le week-end avec une
bande de jeunes de 22 ans j'ai une idée
pour ces vacances avait attaché mois on
devrait partir à 3 m'étais jamais partie
avec les enfants sans moi je te rappelle
que c'est moi à leur mère je me sens
très sérieux j'ai quelques doutes ce à
partir de ce qui va chercher tout ça
à nu soit bien
tous les parents rêvent de passer une
semaine sans leur famille c'est bon tu
entends les valeurs d'entraidé sur des
leaders super g jouer au golf avec des
copines à la retraite vous allez manger
un barbecue improvisé où tu te sens bien
je serais allé à la fête de se défouler
à la misère des enfants les gars qui te
bonjour mon
nom je suis
[Musique]
sereine mais pas pour moi elle est
sous le soleil
c'est le big man au milieu de nulle part
ils sont les petits coins serre ça c'est
des sceaux est inquiète et d'époques
variées
salut bonal où c'est un petit chaton
terrorisés
porté par ses bons mots
histoire d'abus marcel malfait
[Musique]
sauvage c'est peut-être un gros chat
mais lui s'appelle jacques pin pédron
âgées ou était grave orages et les
rockets
là on dirait bat cassidy et le kid tort
prix du service
ta tro bien utilisés dont tu auras toi
qu'est ce qui s'est passé un homme
différent ce fait les choses dont je
suis pas très fier
ces quelques temps on dirait une chipeau
cramé j'ai attendu pendant qu est ce qui
vient ce qui me fait toujours faire des
trucs débiles et faut qu'ils passent
ensemble c'est toujours des trucs de
malade mais là je trouve que c'est tout
match aller
j'arrive au bout des bras en position
étoiles de mer
je t'avais dit que j'y arriverai je
t'aime match je connais
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]